good morning Millennials good morning
Louise D Ortiz welcome to the show thank
you very much we are so excited to have
you here today the toasters are so
excited that you're joining us everyone
is such a big fan of yours
wants to know what you're up to which we
will get into all the questions that
everyone has for you but in the meantime
welcome thank you how are you enjoying
your stay here so far very much I've
been having a lot of fun we've been here
for about 30 minutes already have had
two coffees I'm having conversations at
the lifetime I'm smiling I'm happy oh
that's so great that's what we that's
what we strive for here at the morning
toast so you are million we're on
million dollar listing New York great
and you left to just take a break pursue
your passions travel etc like giving us
major wanderlust on social media how has
that been for you and now that you're
back in New York how is being back in
New York I think it's you know I think
that sometimes we do something for so
long that it becomes sort of a habit and
slowly starts to come to define who we
are
mm-hm and it is very important to
sometimes take a step back and ask
yourself the question as why am i doing
what I once loved so much and do I still
love it as much as I did when I started
it because I personally don't believe
that you're in this life just to do one
thing I think you should be able to do
as many things as possible and you know
to create wisdom and experience and
things like that and I think that after
doing real estate for 12 years I got to
a point where I was I don't longer knew
if I liked it anymore but I was good at
it I was doing great at it and therefore
I should be liking it but I said no and
then I am I took a step back and he just
went to Paris and left everything in one
month I remember I decided I was leaving
New York in February and in March first
I was already in Paris with all my
luggage and I sold everything oh my god
that's that's the hard part is like the
logistics of moving somewhere and
selling everything and like hiring
movers
than going to Paris yeah well good thing
for me I didn't own that many things I I
always like to be mobile because I moved
once a year to a new apartment in 12
years in New York I had 11 apartments
holy said yes I tried every single
neighborhood you could possibly imagine
I started in Queens and then I migrated
to Midtown West and I move it to
financial district in Battery Park in
Chelsea
then Midtown East then 42nd and 12 which
I don't know why was I there but I was
there then Paris and now back downtown
okay well I'm actually moving which is
why selfishly I wanted you to come on
the show because I just want to get your
pulse on all things New York real estate
so since you've actually lived in every
single neighborhood what was your
favorite neighborhood I personally like
downtown south of 14th Street I am an
artist by heart and I like I like
neighborhoods that are not that are
still don't they're not necessarily
defined by it by a society you're very
specific perception they're defined by
what you really used to make them like
you know in downtown like for example
Barry I like it a lot because there's a
lot of artists there is a lot of like
old New York it has that sense of
neighborhood where there's people that
have been have businesses there for 60
years plus and they've been you know
pass along my family members and it just
has that like like quintessential New
York the one that I like it's dirty a
little bit too clean well if you go
anywhere in New York these days it's
dirty so yep you can find some of that
well I'm gonna get your tips for moving
me of so many viewer questions for you
on a personal level on a business level
I am single and that yeah we got that
question a lot you're single that's good
to know are you dating no are you
looking today always are you want any
apps I used to be on tinder but medicine
work it does not work I think that after
you do it for a while it just becomes a
habit and you just girls girls well
anybody if you actually match with
someone you just don't follow up yeah I
think we were married yes I just got
married but I met my husband and on an
asphalt plus we like met at work but we
had matched on a dating app so between
the two yeah so I we match unhinge over
the summer like four years at three
years about four years ago
and then two months later I started a
new job at the company that he was
working at and i coincidentally matched
but i never said i never opened his
message or anything just cuz I was like
busy and I just got a lot of messages no
I'm kidding
so we started working together we met
one night like at a company kickball
game and we were talking and we were
actually like had a lot of chemistry and
then he said to me he was like you know
that we matched unhinge and I was like
um no but I need to go die thank you
goodbye
I was like so embarrassed because I was
already so awkward at work and I was
like I'm now I have a crush on this
special one so you like them without
knowing that you've seen him before
yes but he knew that like he knew that
we had matched but I did did you like
him when you Mascis you'd had to know
that you met Eliot's in some point even
though you got about yeah then when I
went back to his profile I was like oh I
remember this profile like he said he
worked out I hurried in love at first
sight twice yeah I guess so
so anyways if we hadn't been both on the
dating app I don't think that we would
have like matched in real life because
we wouldn't have like he wouldn't have
like flagged me you know or known that I
was interested in him we've actually
been talking about dating apps a lot
this week on the show I think it's
because four out of our five couples
this week are men and you know what I'm
really enjoying it yeah if you are
looking to date I personally recommend
hinge okay and then there's also you
know the celebrity dating app it's like
Fight Club you know first rule is you
don't talk about Riya so if you're on
and I'm sure you just can't tell me I
was never accepted into it but it's fine
now
yeah you can't say that you're on earth
if you are that's like the rule I guess
I don't know
well okay are you on it yes but I'm good
what's the point of like being on Bravo
if you're not gonna be like I'm riot to
meet some fellow Suns have you met what
happened to like the old-fashioned good
friend introducing you to someone who
she thinks it's perfect for you and then
you actually meet her and she happens to
be well I feel like that's everyone's
dream ever no one wants to consider like
think of themselves as someone who has
to be on a dating app you donate that
you've done a bad job or anything right
there in the done a bad job yeah she's
not a very bad job
he's made out with a few of her friends
but it hasn't gotten past that obviously
the toaster is a fine bunch and so
you'll probably get some DMS after this
do you check your DMS um well I haven't
been on Instagram in a while okay it's
you don't even like learn you know I
will I left Instagram and I temporarily
disable the account so you don't have
access to it okay I just recently joined
again because there is some information
I had to pick up from a DM and when you
get back on Instagram you have seven
days until you can disable it again so
now it's there and then I see the MS and
there's there's a bunch of them and then
I just scroll through them but I'm
waiting for my seventh date so I can get
back out again it's been incredible let
me tell you being off of Instagram yes
what have you done with all the time you
have that is crazy that you have done
this question in this world well I'll
tell you something I think that okay so
you your head you have Instagram right
then you have a certain people that you
follow or however people you follow and
they happen to be the people that go on
your knee on your on your feed so in a
way your day and your perception of your
life is defined by everything that
you've seen the people that you're
following and and whatever you're
learning from those things right so
imagine all of a sudden that's the news
that you see in a daily basis and you
stop then there's new things that are
coming along that you're like wow I
wasn't paying attention to that because
my direction of what I have to pay
attention on a daily basis is its its
inspirated or stimulated by the things
that I follow so all of us are I mean
the world becomes so much bigger at
least that's the way I saw it and
imagine having that times I've been out
for like six months seven months uh-huh
Wow you go back to like what he used to
be so how do your life so do you even
want to go back now you know I I'm not
saying I don't have anything against it
I did it because I realized I needed to
step away from it for a little bit and
then while I was away from it I started
to enjoy it and then realize that I was
like more in touch with the things that
were meaningful and I was more prescient
yeah and I no longer took pictures for
it yeah I took pictures for myself which
was a different thing when I was in
Instagram I was taking pictures thinking
about something I was going to
of course and that's natural that's okay
but if you have a balance between both
of them I think it's actually very good
but I want I have to come back because
you know it's a it's a great way to
being communication with you know with
fans and with family members and friends
and and also it's like a big part of the
real estate world today yes is social
media it's been for a while and yes so
like it's work for us you know I can say
like I spend too much time on Instagram
but then I can also justify it as well
just work yeah it is I mean that's
that's how people know you're here so
people actually follow right doing on a
day to day but there are definitely some
days where it goes beyond work and it's
just like an obsession do you are you
completely open on social media or you
keep it private
Oh even though you're I'm pretty open
about my life on social media but it's
like I don't know that you've made your
husband impinge yeah oh yeah everyone
knows that story at this point I think I
told it like three times this week alone
so I think but I think they do a pretty
good job of like being very public you
know showing like most of my life but
then like if I ever want to pull back
it's not so Starbucks where did she go
it's like I pretty much always have like
an Instagram story at least one it's
very rare when I don't but um I can be
like watching TV and filming man it's
not really like spotlight on me that's a
good balance you know so I feel like I
do an okay job that's good but I'm also
just like a millennial woman so you got
to be in the game it's yeah you know
it's you can't be against it you have to
join it it's just a way of this that's
evolving yeah you know when when like
our parents or grandparents say you know
what society's being lost by this this
is just the way it is whether you like
it or not right it's evolving and you
either have to understand that you're
you get left behind so for any of the
toasters out there who might be like
thinking about sliding into your DMS
like what are you looking for what's
your type we're talking about
relationship um you know I've learned I
don't have a type I learned that I like
to be surprised I learned that I like
mysteriousness and spontaneous I still
don't know how to pronounce that word
property on tonight spontaneity
and I've been into Indian women recently
okay you know who's your celebrity crush
never knew I know it's such a hard
question no it's just perhaps I'm not
there's not a celebrity that I am like
there's they're pretty something some
woman that walks down the street I'm
like whoa she's might today crushed and
I think about have you ever dream of
someone that you've never met and she
becomes her crush he becomes your crush
honestly no it's happened to me I
falling in love with a woman that I
haven't met who I don't know how her
what her face looks like but I dream
about her and I know about the way she
makes me feel so therefore it tells me
that I don't have a crush I just have
like that sounds like a movie you should
make it right after you're done with all
the other things that you're doing
anyways without further ado we are here
to deliver the news sent me you need to
know this morning so here are the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast yet it's a lot of
different meanings of toast so it's like
morning toast like avocado toast however
you like your toast with butter but also
you know if you're like trying to have a
good time it's a toast
oh yes Cheers yes I think that's
actually how it originally started but
we'll just take any form of toes
whatever and yeah we're getting toasted
okay
speaking of getting toasted Diana Ross
celebrated her 75th birthday party and
brought out almost Super Bowl 75 brought
out almost all of Hollywood who really
dressed up for the occasion and for that
I so appreciate this party because I
just love when people get dressed up
because I don't think people do it
enough anymore you know I mean you like
they were telling me to only wear suits
yeah now you don't own any suits no so
then what are you wearing regular day a
tuxedo jacket well this I wore it for
you you know I appreciate it I wore my
businesswoman heels for you I was like
these are shoes that a realtor would
wear yeah I'm not just a real no no I'm
saying like like I'm was just stepping
into a real estate mode I'm not saying
you would wear these shoes I'm saying
you would respect a woman who wears a
pump I respect any woman and I respect
any woman that would I wouldn't think
any person that would actually dress
nice right oh I haven't been dressed
nice lately
I just don't want to dress up I just
think what I think it's the winter it's
almost over what during spring everyone
likes to dress up you know everyone
wants to all of a sudden go to happy
hour and get drinks yeah I like your
shoes though
Thank You Ted Baker he's a good guy
Diana Ross is still that diva who can
get just about every single major celeb
from multiple generations to show up in
one iconic venue to celebrate her 75th
birthday the Motown legend finally hit
the big 75 Tuesday with the blowout
party at the Hollywood Palladium that
featured an incredible who's who guest
list from family like her kids Tracee
Ellis Ross and Evan Ross and Ashlee
Simpson - Berry Gordy Beyonce Heidi Klum
Bette Midler Stevie Wonder Kris Jenner
Kourtney and Khloe Kardashian Robin
Thicke Davey and Chris Rock even Leo
showed up and while he was definitely
the most underdressed dude it was a
classic leo look honestly this party
looked so lit and I'm just like jealous
I wasn't there but also excited for
everyone who was Ashley soon was
Jessica's daughter-in-law
daughter-in-law was hurler ashley said
her husband is Evan Ross so I Diana Ross
you know who's obviously a legend is
also better known as Ashlee Simpsons
mother-in-law okay Jessica son used to
have a sister yes what's your name she
has the sister Ashley Simpson see a
month aback no I used to have a crush on
her when I was 15 years old ashley said
she's a pumpkin like their endless
savage yeah she was just sexy to me that
is so crazy that you had a bigger crush
on her than Jessica Santino cuz I don't
you know you like you don't look like
you likes her emo I just like how do you
stuff oh she she was the S year sister
well now she's married to Diana Ross is
son and if they're actually pretty cute
they have a show on E
I've never watched it um I don't know if
they got a second season so I don't know
if it was a success but it looked like
they were having fun that's all that
matters that's all that matters
so you're not so out of tight though
have you become well it's probably cuz
you're not on Instagram that it's easier
for you you lose a lot of touching like
things that are having in the day-to-day
but it's like for us it's of the utmost
importance to know these things because
that's our job but at the end of the day
if you didn't know that Ashlee Simpson
is married to Evan Ross like you're
still gonna be okay I just knew that I
liked her and only three was tuned into
this show like once a month and then I
be done and you'll actually like knowing
absolutely everything that's going on
it's kind of nice I'm sure it is cuz
everyone's around like I know too much
then we go on vacation and like so much
stuff happens in a week and I feel like
I don't know anything and then I'm just
like back does it feel like that for you
when you go to vacation yeah like
sometimes I feel so out of touch if I'm
not because when we do the show even if
every day after the show I don't read up
on everything in the morning when I come
to pick the stories I am forced to read
through everything to pick the stories
that we like so I know what's going on
okay you know what's going on in my life
ooh you're a mister you're a mystery you
are it's hard when you're not on social
media but because I've been in
communication with your people I think I
know more than the average person mm-hmm
but it's just you know you getting to
know yourself yes exciting time and
being back in New York yep okay next
story was very shook worthy because the
Kardashian season trailer was released
and I thought the trailer was already
released but then I watched this one I
was like no this is the trailer for some
reason well was it released before like
a trailer but this was like the dramatic
version where they really go into Chloe
Jordan interest in which I am sure is
some do you know what happened I do know
about that
you do yes well I don't know about that
I've been reading about it I've seen
okay that's like that that's a good
place to start
Khloe Kardashian sobs over Tristan
Thompson and keeping up with the
kardashians trailer quote he has no
respect for me the new season of Keeping
Up with the Kardashians is almost here
and from the looks of a new trailer
released today it won't be short on
drama though season 16 was mostly
finished filming before the news of
Jordan was in Tristan Thompson cheating
scandal broke it appears that the season
will feature Khloe Kardashian and
Thompson's first cheating scandal as a
plotline
according to bustle the season
officially wrapped after the woods drama
but it's unclear how much will be
included in the season that's weird
because according to the trailer it
looks like it's all about the woods
drama it's about a prior cheating
scandal in which case how many
them why now why this cheating scandal
you ever see Legally Blonde eh
I didn't know yes I don't remember I
just remember you would remember her
okay stop
I let me let me think of the name um
Reese Witherspoon yes I'm so proud of my
expert yes thank you so much birth
status but first the cheating scandal
should provide enough drama to last a
season in April 2018 just days before
cloacae birth to true photos and videos
surfaced of Thompson getting close to
other women which was highly documenting
on the last season so if this is what
we're in store for
I am NOT interesante but hopefully it's
a little more salacious than that
because it looks really crazy mm-hmm I
never cheated on anyone
me neither good yeah but like a lot of
people have a lot of people have been
cheated on it's becoming a lot like look
uh I mean it's always been a thing right
yeah I think so but I think now with
social media it makes it easier for
people you don't have to go to a bar to
meet someone like someone slides into
your DMS and then you can especially
when you're famous as I'm sure you know
yeah I mean I think it's all about
communication right if you communicate
then there's no problem
yeah hopefully have you met him the
Kardashians I have met Kim actually met
Kim a couple of times I met her first at
NBC up front because right it's yours
where sister networks yes hey Bravo and
II and she was great
she's always been great and then I
showed her an apartment once and she was
also great actually obviously you wanted
to keep everything very quiet but
paparazzi's were all over the place so
they're already like setting up outside
where we're showing oh and then Fredrik
also show her an apartment I think
actually I think he showed more than
three apartments where was she looking
what neighborhoods ah she was looking
everywhere did she have good taste yes
yes they actually all the families their
homes are very nice yeah they're very
tastefully done I think you and I saw an
article in our Kazuko digest about
Carly's and she's very tasteful when it
comes to designing I think it's great I
think it's great too yeah it's so true
and they're also like pretty feminine
but they keep it neutral yeah well her
mother a Kris mm-hmm she has great taste
as well I saw a video in architecture
just they've been posting Arkady's mean
a lot of articles on this girls I mean I
think it's good and I think that means
that they're very in tune because I feel
like a lot of people when they're
decorating their houses now they say
like I want it to look like a car - they
have a certain style and that's really
like what's popular right now like if I
were to like own and design a home I
would be like I want Kardashian floors
and Kardashian marble wow you know what
a friend right crazy that's crazy what's
your style it changes a lot I've changed
a lot every once in a while but right
now at the moment I like like my
apartment before I used to have doorman
buildings with all the amenities right
now I live in a very old 1800 building
with high ceilings exposed brick walls
and very old columns right in the middle
and all wood floors that when you walk
you hear the crackles oh wow painted in
gray that's so cool
yeah a very industrial so much like
character you don't get that in like a
doorman building where everything is
like a yeah well because you have all
this developers building fast buildings
and you just need to make as many
apartments as possible in order to get
you know much more money and the image
in it's cheap construction - right I
supposed to like the old buildings where
you have the facade with all the you
know with all the crown moldings all the
beautiful architecture will be dismissed
off anything there are so many buildings
going if you live in New York then you
already know like so many buildings
going up like in Chelsea on the west
side it's crazy out here do you think
that is good for the industry well the
market is it's it's not in a good place
right now there's a lot of inventory
there's not a lot of buyers there's a
lot of new tax laws being implemented on
people that are buying secondary homes
that it's not even attractive for people
moving to New York there so you know
it's a there's a crazy market sold right
now and then this developers they bought
the land for sold so much so expensive
that now they have to sell this
apartment that I had you in hire expend
a more expensive price and if people are
not buying then they're just keeping it
there yeah so it's a tough time it's
awesome what did you think about Amazon
coming to New York they're no longer I
know were you for them coming or ant
against uh I don't really have an
opinion at the moment about it but um
you know I think if it provides jobs why
not yeah but I was I was always looking
at them as a client yeah you would have
have been selling a lot of apartments a
lot of apartments and even get on the
commercial side because there's so
that's that's a big business - yeah very
true okay well speaking of Bravo shows
Bravo announces a new show called Tech's
economist Bravo is heading south with a
twist it's a cute name
Texarkana so the network's newest [ __ ]
series follows six Mexican women in San
Antonio Texas as they go about their
daily lives but he in a unique twist the
shell will be narrated from the
perspective of one of the women penny
that's so interesting
penny who was born in the United States
but States but spent her youth in Mexico
will be in the middle of the drama and
on top of the stripper pole in her
living room she and her husband Rob will
own a successful real-estate company and
share two sons Texas is booming from
real estate oh yeah and I've never been
to San Antonio have you yes what's it
like I was just there for one day I went
for a speaking engagement there and I
went on Tuesday it was very empty so I
just went to a bar and drink it was it
like a real country vibe yes a little
bit where I was it wasn't that much but
people were dressed up like oh that's
well originally I think the show was
originally intended to be Real
Housewives of San Antonio because they
were filming in a while back and I saw
in our morning Twitter Facebook group
where all the best gossip is they had
filmed the women at some restaurant or
something and I guess now they switched
to not be Real Housewives and it's
called text economist was just cute I
always took to kind of even more right
yeah it like rolls off the tongue and I
feel like as long as the show is
semi-decent like people will want to
watch I think people will start using
that name um attack Sakana yeah now
you're Texarkana what color what's your
type of women taxi Kaunas taxi Candace
that's where it's at like though Maya
pho then they profile all the other
women in the group um and I'm really
just not interested one of them is a
perfectionist I don't give a [ __ ] but I
but I will be watching the show which
premieres May 7th on Bravo okay so much
I will be watching I love I always love
a new show I want them like I want Bravo
and eat
rise that's very nice I want Bravo I
need his rife you know I like bravo
Bravo Bravo was a great network to be a
part of yeah yeah do you like going on
my travels I've yes I love Andy I think
he's great and it's always fun and it's
at night I do better at night than I do
in the morning sorry
and no it's all good how did you get
involved in the show like what was the
casting process like well I I started on
season 2 and there was already someone
in season 1 Michael Lorber who was an
agent there and for some reason he was
not coming back on season 2 and so they
were looking for a new cast member and I
think they already started the ideation
process since I'm not two in touch with
what's happening in the world especially
in that world I didn't know anything
about it in one days I some I got a call
from someone in LA saying that they just
wanted to interview me I think somebody
was going through like real estate
website pages okay and look at it agents
that work for companies and they saw a
picture and they saw my bio and said my
listings and then they called me
I went a Bishan for them and I remember
they told me I think you're too nice for
this show and when they said that I said
I kind of want this like what does that
mean I'm too nice for this show because
I'm looking for drama you know yeah and
I thought was not gonna get it and then
two weeks later I got an email saying
you know we would like to meet you from
a late so the producers flew into LA met
me and then I start shooting and they
never told me it was officially a cast
member until like I was just I just kept
shooting and shooting that is so crazy
and do you ever think you would like do
television well I want to be a film
director when I was a kid that's the
reason I came to New York and so I was
always behind the camera yeah and then I
started enjoying and being comfortable
in front of the camera and then then I
found a way to be able to tell stories
while being in front of camera so I kind
of love that uh-huh and then I just
discover new things that I didn't before
and yes I love it I think it's great
especially when you're being you because
you're exploring you you're growing
yourself and then you're learning you're
learning so much but you the business
yes so do you still stay in touch with
Fredrik and Ryan I stay in touch with
Fredrik a lot I know Ryan just had a
baby I haven't met her baby his baby
Frederic's babies are amazing oh really
oh my god they're so cute his baby Mia
which I'm in love with her he says
replica Frederic in a smaller version
with I was gonna say for joining about
this it's a girl have you met the new
agency gold yes yes I've met him I've
met her in Paris he he went to Paris
when they went when they were filming
there he was there I've also met him
before that we did a deal together but
we never actually met we just did it the
over email okay
and he's great that's good business yes
yes you know he's very laid-back relaxed
which is uh I think a style that you
know he's very recognized by it
people like him on the trail I saw I saw
what I've heard and but he's a great guy
yeah yeah he's a cool dude we found him
a bunch of times on exam what do you
think I really like him yeah he's fun
but I think you're my new favorite no
thank you my new favorites I was never a
favorite um I never like played flavor
its but now that we're talking like yeah
you're my favorite okay next up Seth
Rogen rolls out a new cannabis company
houseplant Seth Rogen is sure to have
another hit on his hands with his newly
launched Canadian cannabis company house
plant which will not only sell
recreational marijuana products but
hopes to educate users as well Rogen and
his filmmaking partner Evan Goldberg who
have become kings of stoner comedy via
movies like pineapple Express co-founded
the company on and on Wednesday Rogen
offered a sneak peak on Instagram with
photos of a warehouse full of weed plans
and printed packaging the houseplant
website which features a retro design
inspired by VHS tapes currently is one
we product for sale sad TiVo what's a
great product for sale a sativa strain
with indica and hybrid strains coming
soon I don't know what that means
I guess it's just really yeah the site
also says that the company aims to
educate users beyond safe and
responsible use of cannabis products
well this seems like a match made in
heaven
Seth Rogen in cannabis yeah yes and now
like in all of his like a STONER movies
true he could be selling his own
products inside his movies uh-huh that's
true I love him you don't think he's
amazing I've met him once and he's
exactly the same person you would see
that's so amazing yeah
and I'm not so big like honestly that
movie pineapple Express
yes I really didn't like it I don't
think I even finished it I just thought
it was like so dirty
super bad I like super bad I like most
of his movies so I don't know what the
most recent ones were like a interview I
love the interview did you see it yes
yes even though it was so crazy to see
it because then North Korea was gonna
come out of your door yeah that was a
really crazy time that was a risky move
to yeah uh but anyways this seems like
it makes a lot of sense and would you
try it his stuff mm-hmm yes of course
yeah he seems to be the expert on yes a
hundred percent and I'm sure he'll do
things that are actually very like funny
oriented like things that will make you
very happy yeah and you know creative
and a hundred percent totally good luck
to him good luck to him
honestly and it seems like a good like a
really good idea like whoever his
management is they this is a great
commercial channel for him to go down he
has a movie coming out now right a new
movie comes yes with um Charlize Theron
yes he's like a can't I think it's
called the candidate or something
something like that it looks really good
it's his movie he wrote it I guess he
brights mostly yes and I think is a bit
more like like take on comedy but a
little bit more serious agreed so like
oscar-worthy kind of perhaps that would
be great that would be great it actually
looks really good I don't know if it's
coming out in theatres or on Netflix I
can't keep up anymore
yeah probably one of them too but it's
kind of the same cuz that fish is
already wanting the Oscars so yeah crazy
nothing's it's just a big as a buyer as
its to do so mm-hmm and Netflix is
coming out real estate shows I just
watched a trailer for like selling
Sunset have you seen it no it's I didn't
watch the show I just watched it real
estate show about selling real estate in
LA about selling real estate on Sunset
and then it's also about like the women
who work in the office and the drama
between them it's like Vanderpump rules
for real estate I don't know it looks to
be setting women back a few years but it
looks to be interesting
okay and the group is called the
Oppenheim
grupe do you know them yes yes another
company okay yeah I don't know but I'm
sure he's doing something I'm serious
right I'm sure I'll why should
eventually all of it you know I like
what I like about Netflix is that it's
um it doesn't have you know you there's
there's no limitations because you know
you're not affiliated with sponsors it's
just membership so yeah and actually go
the extra mile that's like the show I
think this show yeah ooh speaking of
sponsors we have a really fun one for
you today and release is a thing which
have you heard of audible yes with
audible you get access to an unbeatable
selection of audio books including
bestsellers motivation mysteries
thrillers memoirs and more audio audible
has the largest selection of audiobooks
on the planet and now with audible
originals the selection has gotten even
more custom with content made for
members so I love audible because it
relaxes me
like honestly reading a book will always
put me to sleep but like listening to a
book will just make me feel chill and
and informed can you pick the voice whoo
I think the voice is like built-in like
if it's a memoir you'll hear from the
author but they should have like
difficult I could be listening to Harry
Potter like different I'm sorry
different voices with different accents
I would I would work on that
imagine when if people want to hear the
accent but I would read somebody book oh
you could I feel like you have a nice
voice that could be a next career path
for you I would not be opposed to doing
books on tape yeah go to audible.com
slash TMT or text TMT to five zero zero
five zero zero and listen for a change
that's audible AUD ible calm slash TMT
honestly I highly recommend I've had
like such a terrible migraine yesterday
do you ever get migraines no and I just
needed anything to relax so I like tried
book on tape which was like much better
for me than watching TV what kind of
voice was it it was a soothing voice but
honestly all the books that I read are
like celebrity lols so it's like so
salacious it's definitely not what I
should be listening to but it's it's
been
TV I think it is actually because it
leaves a little bit to your imagination
mm-hmm right when there's somebody's
telling you a story you have to make
your own pictures of it yes it's your
own a podcast like this one mm-hmm okay
our fifth story is a bit of real estate
news and it's sad and just sad for
retail in general
Barney's is downsizing its signature
Madison Avenue store says sources
Barneys New York is looking to reduce
its Manhattan footprint in a move that
could shrink its flagship store by more
than half the post has learned the lux
department store owner is and talks to
gave up as many as five of the nine
floors it occupies on Madison Avenue in
an effort to reduce its hefty 30 million
dollar annual rent sources said if
Barney's succeeds in shrinking its
flagship store it will be the left the
latest in a long line of retailers
pulling up stakes at Tony Manhattan
addresses due to skyrocketing rents and
changing shopping habits Lord & Taylor
shuttered its flagship store on Fifth
Avenue at the beginning of the year
followed by closures by Henri Bendel and
Tommy Hilfiger Henri Bendel was like a
death for me like that one was a sad one
and it wasn't just like downsizing
what's the sad part for you that it
doesn't exist for I'd just love what
they sold I love the energy in the store
so it's not even that they made the
store smaller which they did a long time
ago it said the store doesn't even exist
you can't even just walk in there and
then experience it and like have that
like a hit of fun for a second and
there's no other store in the city
that's really like it except it didn't
really start to to fall behind when they
stopped selling like third party clothes
and accessories now then they just only
sold their own Henri Bendel line which
was less cute in a lot of instances but
like their signature stuff that's like
the brown and white stripe stuff was so
cute I just love the energy of the story
I don't think you got it anywhere else
in the city I think yeah a lot of a lot
of stores are downsizing just to focus
on annex in a smaller experience in
order for you to not even buy on the
store just to have the sense of what the
brand represents and then just go and
buy it online it is it's nice to have a
very big story you can just you know go
from floor to floor or like I feel like
all the time I'll go I want to go
shopping in store I'll go to
Bloomingdale's I'll go to Saks and then
I remember why I shop
because they don't have like when you
shop online you have unlimited options
you have if you like a certain designer
you can find every single piece from the
collection whereas Bloomingdale's or
Saks like your have to trust the buyer
of that sort
you have to like their taste and in a
lot of instances you don't and they all
have the same things I mean have you
been down to Hudson Yards yet mm-hmm
I think that's really exciting for
retail I went to Neiman's but again it
was just like the same [ __ ] I see at
Saks yeah
like wine go there when I can shop at
Farfetch'd and literally shop from a
boutique in Bulgaria I agree actually
why would I go to Britain yards
especially when it's on 12th Street
Avenue and I could just go to
Bloomingdale's but Hudson Yards is more
of a development kind of like yeah
they're trying to make it an experience
which I appreciate but then I so I went
to Neiman's and then I met my friend for
a drink at meelo swine bar and then I
felt like I was drinking at a mall who
wants to get drunk at the mall I did I
did do it but it wasn't ideal yeah and
you know I could have used like a little
outdoor seating I'm sure they're working
on that but anyways I just think like
retail especially in New York which is
like the fashion capital of the world I
think it's really sad where we're headed
well I mean it's it's a 30 million
dollars in rent that's wild I thought
they would own the land no that would be
because the building is at least eighth
floors but I think it's uh they have
offices on top I believe yeah I'm not
sure but they don't they don't
that's how McDonald's actually made
their wealth and real estate I know did
you see the founder mm-hmm yeah great
great movie I think about that all the
time I'm like it's not they're not
selling burgers they're selling real
estate anyways um so who's gonna come in
to that space at Barneys who can afford
it that's a good question so then say
Barneys I mean Lord and Taylor is out
bend else is out like and I think a lot
of other stores are struggling what is
the industry that's gonna come in and be
able to well I think what they'll do is
they'll start shopping space spaces and
rent it to different entities a just for
the location mm-hmm to get higher rents
but lower price per square foot I'm in
but lower price per square foot which
eventually will lead to more money to
the land
but they'll have to restructure their
whole their whole system because there's
not one entity that would lease out that
much space for that price right people
with mobility now and with the access to
Internet and just how everything is so
so flexible people can work from home
people get work from Long Island City
people can work from anyway yeah I need
to be in Fifth Avenue like back in the
day being on fifth was a very
prestigious thing how people rather be
just and you know what's in yours would
be less expensive because it's new yeah
even though it's not that expanded that
these expensive that makes sense because
I feel like now we're starting to see
more of those sorts of like little
communities coming up like Hudson Yards
there have one at Pier 17 and then they
have that one in one world trade where
Lower East Side is also doing another
one Delancey you know and it really is
like a I mean they would probably vomit
if they heard this but it's like a mall
mm-hmm yeah I love them all never wanted
to get to New Yorkers like malls yeah
well they don't I'm the weird New
Yorkers like smalls and country music
but um most like when I go to another
state I just I want to hit them all yeah
I can see that but in New York you kind
of want to go into the store hit the
streets store hit the streets or not
just stay within yeah right it'll be
interesting to see where it goes and who
can afford I mean it's not even a retail
issue it's everywhere you walk up like
First Avenue and everything is just out
of business like the rent is too damn
high the taxes are too high and like who
who can afford it yeah even in Soho
there's a lot of empty retail spaces
it's so sad it's not like it's just sad
that that's New York City which is
supposed to be like the greatest most
bustling city in the country but they're
so you know now people are migrating to
other cities too and there's a lot of
incentives on other states they're
making people go there but now New York
is coming after people who leave New
York they want those taxes I can't and I
shan't with the taxes yeah yeah I can't
I shan't
sometimes I just went okay anyways now
thank you for so much for helping me
deliver that I tried to make that as
Louise friendly as possible what is
loose friendly as possible a little real
estate you know not too much Kardashian
but this is the morning too so I had to
get it in there a little business
you know a whole array which is what I
love to do because it can get tiring
talking about the same thing over and
over again okay fun and now I have a lot
of viewer questions for you and your
super miss if that's a big rock oh thank
you nice thank you very much I enjoyed
it and I'm not a huge like jewelry
person so it's like I just wear this one
I well now I wear it mrs. W what is mrs.
oh that's my house my new last name you
knew that I'm working on adapting yeah
what's his last name Weinreb wine rep
where is that from Texas Texican no he
said he's a Texan that's been about the
cab yeah actually I don't know I should
20 I have to check his 23andme test
problems at home tonight
nope he's like he doesn't even know you
know if he knew then I wouldn't know but
it's like nice except to ask his mom
okay I'm gonna take some viewer
questions for you because everyone
really misses you on social media and
now I've gotten to a lot of like why
you've stopped posting on Instagram what
why Paris when you moved I don't know
why Paris in fact I've never been to
Paris before I moved to Paris do you
just like throw a dart at the map you
mary-kate and Ashley kaya I've always
been a romantic and I've associated
Paris with Romans I think a lot of
people do because of movies and books
and you know favorite writers always
were inspired by my Paris film directors
that I like I've been inspired by Paris
and just I love French movies I love
French cinema very much a root loaf
French wine and I love French music and
French culture but I've never been there
I've loved everything about it that I
have been that I have learned from books
and movies and radio and everything in
between
but I thought if I'm going to make this
into a fantasy might as well just go to
Paris and Paris is also so close by to
all the European countries and that I
thought it was great
headquarters to have what's it
everything you thought it was gonna be
no but it was everything I am but I'm
very grateful of everything that went
down
cuz of that I've learned a lot about I
mean I learned a lot about myself I
learned a lot about being in a place
where nobody knew anything about you
where you knew nothing about the culture
really even though you thought you did
you knew nobody nothing about the
language and you have to just restart
from the beginning and that was
challenging and beautiful at the same
time yeah that's like some people's
biggest fear yes because if you if I was
so comfortable in New York and New York
and I knew everybody in New York and I
was very comforted with my business and
I was very you know I felt like I was
already safe going into a place was was
the opposite of were you of the place
you left almost the same as when you
were when I started in New York at 20
years old but the difference I was now
30
mm-hmm it was very challenging but any
was kind of like should I go back to
safety place but then I said no I should
just stay here and and go at it again
and rebuild myself from scratch and it
was fascinating the things that I
learned about myself I do am I putting
myself in that place and it makes me
almost want to do it again after I
succeed once again it makes me also
makes you also prove to yourself that if
you're able to do it once you can do it
as many times over so where would you go
next well I came back to New York for
now because I realized one thing
regardless of how beautiful the world is
to me there is no place better than New
York City
hands down there's no better a more
efficient place a more for thinking
place a more just exciting and full of
mystery place than New York City
regardless of me being here for 13 14
years I still I just haven't seen even
more than 20% of it do you think the
city's changed a lot since you've been
gone
it's always real estate wisest change
aesthetically and in industry the people
have not have not changed as much which
is also very interesting when you go to
a place for two years and you have seen
so much and things actually feel like
you've been outside of New York for 30
years and you come back and then you see
the same people you left behind with
your same mentality their same problems
their same attitude the same approach
it's kind of like wow I'm glad that I
left because the world has not moved
that fast I thought it was going to yeah
and it makes you almost think that have
I not make that
move I would have probably stayed the
same exact way so it makes you also
almost want to do this as often as
possible mm-hmm so it was it good yeah
that's a good perspective what's your
favorite property that you've ever sold
well I would attach the favorite
property to a good story yeah but I you
know cuz there's there's very expensive
places that are not necessarily good
stories I once sold of like a twenty
million dollar place over an Instagram
post and I didn't even met the owner Wow
and it was just an easy transaction
anyways you know as most people were
very proud of that I'm proud of it
because it took I took myself into a
place where I was able to do that but um
I saw the place that was one owned by
Jackson Pollock and it was a small
studio it was 1.2 million dollars and we
ended up selling it for one point how
much did we sell it for run either one
four six because that was Jackson
Pollock favors number four six he used
to put a lot of four sixes in his
paintings and we found a little bit of
paint inside the like on top of the
floors from like back in the day it was
also the place where Aaron Burr used to
live before he got shot
oh my age Jefferson before he got shot
by Aaron Burr that's so cool
yeah there was a lot of history behind
it and it was fun I also had sex in an
apartment once just once yes just once
with a client she was the one that asked
for it this is true story and I was in
2008 I was just studying real estate she
never ended up renting the apartments
damn mm-hmm she got you she got me so I
think I know the answer to this question
but did you watch the show after you
left yes Oh after I left no no because
in Paris they didn't they did in Eretz
mm-hmm and I was just so focused on
living a new life that I even stopped
watching completely I figured yeah uh is
there anything that you would have
changed about like your a journey on
million dollar listing or anything you
would have done differently no I think
if you if there's anything that you
would change about your life you're
somehow regretting anything about who
you are today
I totally agree and sometimes when you
go into the worst of times you
constantly thought and probably wish
that you could have changed something
but if you're patient enough and you
start to see the results of something so
bad
turning into something so beautiful then
you start saying you know what I'm glad
that it happened so I can say I'm glad
that everything amen my friend what do
you miss most about being on million
dollar listing what do you not miss at
all I miss I miss being able to document
my story as it falls in business and
personal I don't I don't I try not to
divide my life into two things business
and and personal I think that everything
is just a blend of one life and I love
the fact of of seeing how much I grew
seeing my [ __ ] seeing when I did
something wrong and seeing it afterwards
I'm learning from it and doing it better
the next time
and I liked sharing it with the world I
thought it was a very fortunate thing to
have and not taking that for granted
being able to share someone a place of
vulnerability and places of strength and
all of that it's a very beautiful thing
and I would never like I will always
miss that what don't you miss what do I
miss there's nothing that I don't miss I
miss everything about it I just you know
I didn't like I was not enjoying myself
in the business anymore
that's why I left the show but you
weren't not enjoying the show yes in
fact that actually was the one that I
enjoyed the most oh that's so good to
know what's the craziest craziest thing
you've come across while giving a
listing tour sex toys in a fridge you're
opening the fridge sucks your
refrigerator and that's like a big
frozen dildo right there next to a
blueberry pack and you're like and she's
like an you open that again I said no
she says please okay there is that is so
funny everyone wants to know about your
hair what products you use and how long
does it take that is so amazing mm I
don't use a lot of products yeah doesn't
look it looks know I'm not full of
product I blow-dry it when I come out of
the shower and then sometimes I use a
little bit of wax
and then just think that since it's nice
see they got a nice flow thank you so a
little bit of New York real estate what
do you think is the best if you're
buying an apartment like the best part
of town to buy and that will really hold
it's worth I think that real estate
changes so much and society changes with
it and the other way around that right
now I wouldn't necessarily I mean what
what location used to mean back then
it's not the same anymore because
location used to be defined by the best
restaurants and the highest society and
you know things that were more promising
I think right now there is so many
different pockets and you know not
having not being close to something you
know and there's there's so many trends
that that finds different groups of
societies that there is a there's a
pocket for everyone and eventually
everything it's becoming something good
you know with with food and
entertainment and you know and in social
media that actually addresses new trends
and celebrities that choose to be in
specific places for specific reasons I
think that anything that has up site it
should be a good place to to live being
ahead of the trend it's always but
Laurie site alphabet city in New York
it's a great area there's places like
Texas in Texas is its booming a lot yeah
and you know techno with technology also
yeah everything that everything is
changing so fast like Fifth Avenue
people are you know Fifth Avenue is so
expensive right now I wouldn't live
there
you wouldn't I would not it's to pay
that much to be next to something that I
don't necessarily spend that much time
in mm-hmm
I don't know it's not as young as I like
it to be that's true I have a question
for you so Friedrich had a show with
Bethany where they flipped us apartments
together which was really cool if you
did a show like that who would you want
to do it with
it could be any she's saying me ronita I
would do a show it runny that any died
in Victoria also Victoria and you I
would be surrounded by women all around
because they make life much more
interesting it's incredible
do you watch any like design shows like
chip and Joanna Gaines no no no but I
like them I like that I like to watch em
I love design I think design it's it
actually helps create a perception of
everything that it's not showing from
the core part of it I think design it's
just like dressing you know it's it
actually stimulates the character of a
place that is not necessarily showing it
off the bat and I love design you know
if you've seen my every apartment that
I've ever had it's it's always very it
always represents what my character of
that time is yeah and but yeah I would
do a show about designing places around
the world I like to travel
you know travel show travel show that's
mixed with design and it's mixed with
food of course I love food and wine and
life that's a really this sounds like a
great show
yeah yeah we should look into it okay
one more question for you before I let
you guys yes what is a piece of advice
that you would give to an aspiring agent
I think it's the same advice I would
give to any inspiring person to any
aspire inspirational venture I think
it's very important to focus on the
things that you like I know that it's
been said many many times over but I
think that's you know sometimes what we
like today is not necessarily what we
like tomorrow and it's that's okay it's
it's it's is the nature of human beings
being curious and being ever-evolving
species right I think it's so very
important to ask yourself the question
of what it what's the reason behind what
you're doing on a daily basis because
those who change as well and I think
that we should not take ourselves too
seriously I think that we should not
compare ourselves to the next-door
person I think everybody has a certain
speed as to as how they run in their own
life I think everybody has their own
rhythm and I think that with the fact
that you know the more we compare
ourselves to somebody else that perhaps
seem more successful because
the rest of the world seems to think
that that person is more successful the
more we slow down around on our own life
and I think that we are the only factors
in our own characters in our own lives
and I think we should write it the way
we want to and we should not let outside
influence dictate our speed and how our
life should be unfolded I think we
should be inspired by it but not let us
dictate and I think that we should enjoy
every moment that we have in this world
because we're very lucky to be a part of
it and I think that we should not be
embarrassed about anything we do we
should always own absolutely every
mistake that we make a mistake
are also defined by whatever is not
right but who says that mistakes are not
the other way around I think we should
just enjoy every minute and be grateful
for it well thank you that is such a
nice note to end on also someone came up
with a really great idea for a show for
you called million dollar vacation also
Claudia is going to be on daily pop
today Claudia is my sister who usually
sits in that seat she's admin la she's
gonna be on daily pop it starts at noon
Eastern Time so once you tune off here
go too much into not only show with your
sister oh my god we love it we just had
the best time that's so funny
you'll have to meet you would love her
she's literally hilarious and so I'm so
excited to watch her be hilarious today
I'm daily pop so head over to e now
thank you so much Weiner to everyone
follow you Louise do your tease okay my
Instagram I'm still actually there now
because I had the 7 day period before I
leave
oh maybe I'll stay from you in your
Instagram and I feel like you have such
exciting things coming up anything that
you can tease or share with us I have a
lot of projects that's the reason I came
back to New York nothing I can
unfortunately share at the moment but I
have one of the biggest news in my
personal life happening at the moment
and that I can't share and I have also a
I'm working on television too something
coming up soon and I can't share it
either
well we'll be staying tuned very excited
we'll be following along on Instagram
whether or not you're posting in three
months I'll be able to share it stay
tuned that's nothing
we're patient bye
over here anyways thank you all for
tuning in today we'll be back tomorrow
with Ben for our Friday episode and it's
gonna be really fun of my final episode
of my jackieo takeover week which has
been a lot of male energy and you know
what I'm feeling it thank you for
joining us thank you for having me great
to be here with you have a great day
everyone head over to eat daily pop
peace
you